we found a new pattern in the primes uh
one that we
didn't know was there primes don't like
to repeat their last digits
it's really really strange so prime
could end with a one three a seven or a
nine i mean the exceptions are two
itself which obviously ends in a two and
five itself but apart from that uh they
end with a one a three a seven or nine
right and because we you know we hope
that primes are random or they feel like
they're kind of appear randomly that
each one of those should be equally
likely and something strange has
happened
so some mathematicians in stanford have
looked at this and they've looked at
consecutive primes
and they've noticed things like if a
prime ends in a nine
it's actually more likely to for the
next prime to end in a one
rather than
a nine or three or a seven and so you
would expect all of those to be equally
likely to turn up next but when they did
it and they looked at the first 100
million primes and when they did that if
you had a prime ending in a nine the
chance the next prime
ended in a
nine was 18
uh which is not a quarter and the chance
that they ended in a one
was greater than a quarter it was 32
it shouldn't be that shouldn't be how it
is but that's what they found out let's
find out why this is so if the primes
are random then these prime endings here
one three seven and nine they should
each appear about a quarter of the time
and
if we had the consecutive primes and we
looked at their prime endings
we would have 16 options you'd have a
one and a one so that'd be a prime
ending and by inner one followed by
prime ending in a one
or you could be a one followed by a
three
or one followed by seven or one followed
by nine and these are the options okay
there are 16 options when you're looking
at two consecutive primes so
if it was random they should all appear
1 16th of the time equally likely of the
time but that's not what they found at
all in particular these diagonal
entries here so the one one three three
seven seven nine nine
are
at least likely to turn up so the primes
aren't repeating themselves and there's
a few explanations for why this could be
the case uh which i'm going to dismiss
all right i'm going to give you a few
explanations which aren't the reason why
this is happening so one might be
okay if you have a prime ending with a
nine
then well you have to go through all the
other numbers before you get to another
prime ending with a nine all you have to
go through the numbers that end with a
one and a three and a seven before you
get to another number ending with a nine
so it's further away it's further away
right so um unfortunately that isn't
enough to explain the bias that we found
if that's the case then we're looking
for
prime gaps less than 10 right that means
you know the next one is less than 10 so
it's you know you're going for the prime
ending with a one next or prime ending
with a three next
and prime gaps less than 10 are
not that many and so that's not enough
to explain how biased this is the bias
is bigger than that so that's no good
another
explanation might be
i said that these prime endings one
three seven and nine if this was a
random
thing they should be appearing a court
at the time each maybe the explanation
is that that's not a true thing uh maybe
the bias comes from uh the primes
themselves uh and that doesn't work out
either there is a slight bias in the
primes and it's something we know about
it's called shebachev's bias and it says
that primes ending in three and seven
are slightly more likely that is
something we know about we know why that
happens and it's such a slight thing
it's it's not enough so there's this
known bias in prime number endings so
under that assumption the pair 3 3 and 7
7 should turn up more often right
and the whole the complete opposite is
true in fact three three and seven seven
are the least likely that are turning up
which is the exact opposite of what it
should be and nine one are actually the
most common pair
which is not what it should be at all
okay maybe oh maybe it's just a base 10
thing you know based
who cares about base 10 right if it was
a fundamental property of primes it
would happen in any base
and it does that's what they found so
they checked it on other bases and they
found the bias is still there so it
appears to be a fundamental property of
the primes for example if we drew it in
base three uh it will only end with a
one or two or unless it's three itself
right we can ignore that one you've got
two endings they should turn up about
fifty percent of the time each which is
about right again shepherd chef speyer
says it's a little slight bias towards
the two but uh it's tiny it's pretty
much 50 50. it's pretty much a coin toss
in fact that's what inspired this
investigation and the guys who were who
did this investigation
were thinking about coin tosses and so
they thought well primes in base three
are like a coin toss let's just see if
that does the same thing because that's
a random event
and and then they found this completely
different thing that there's this this
skew
that times don't like to repeat
themselves and that's not something that
would happen in coin tosses so if we did
it in base three we would have four
prime endings wouldn't we we'd have one
one uh one two two one and two two and
again they found the same thing
these ones with the repetition are the
least likely to occur they look the
first million primes and if you look at
the first million primes then they
should all be equally likely she'll turn
up a quarter of the time 250 000 but no
they didn't get that
so these ones with the repetition were
less than 250 000 the ones without a
repetition were more than 250 000. so
the mathematicians who have been
investigated this have tried to come up
with an explanation for this and their
explanation uh relies on a conjecture
that goes back 100 years it's a
conjecture by hardy and littlewood and
they had a conjecture about the density
of primes how many primes you can find
in patterns
so you can consider all kinds of
patterns like twin primes that's a
pattern or cousin primes which have gaps
of four or sexy primes you have gaps of
six so they had this conjecture about
how many of these you should find
and the conjecture has not been proven
there's a lot of evidence that supports
that it's true so if you look at the
numerical evidence it appears to be true
but it hasn't been proven so the
mathematicians looking at this pattern
used a modified version of that
conjecture and they came up with a
formula that they think might explain
this idea so the formula was so the
proportion of this pattern let's say
you've got prime endings a and b so if
we're doing it in base 10 this could be
1 1 or 3 seven or nine one and so we're
looking at the proportion of these
endings and they came up with a formula
the formula was one over the number of
allowed endings uh so this this is like
1 16 from what i've been doing in base
10 right so when it's equally likely
these are the allowed endings there 16
of them
so the proportion is one over the
allowed endings multiplied by a thing
right and what is this thing okay that
thing depends
on uh if that pattern repeats if it's uh
if you've got a equals b
in that formula if a equals b that will
affect what that thing
is i'll show you what it looks like in
base three it's kind of it's kind of
okay in base three we're looking at
proportions of these endings if they're
the same like this a a
so that would be in basically the one
one
endings and the two two endings the
proportion is
if you were doing it when they're not
equal so if it was uh the one two
endings or the two one the proportion of
a b and i'm saying a is not
the same as b
plus so this formula they've got it's
still conjectured formula because it is
based on this hardy little word formula
which is still a conjectured formula but
it fits the evidence once we start going
off to infinity
this bias becomes less and less
important this is a bias that is hanging
around so in the great infinity of
numbers this bias is evening out but
even up to a trillion there's still a
noticeable bias there
audiobooks are a great way to pass time
if for example you spend a lot of time
commuting and with over 250 000 titles
in its collection audible.com is the
place to find something you'll enjoy for
your first book why not go for the
humans by matt haig it's a cracking
story it's funny charming and without
giving too much away i think it'll
really appeal to numberphile fans it's
been one of my favorite books in a while
why not give them a try you can actually
sign up for a free 30-day trial at
audible.com
numberphile use that address and they'll
know you came from here and thanks to
audible for supporting this video